ah
second time around what do you go to
school for brother
counting that's awesome nice good that's
good and uh how did you do the first
time around i assumed didn't work out
you know he's going for his doctorate
are you picking up the same place you
left off same schooler now
nice is it just an online situation
okay fair enough all right good
that's
about to ask you how the football team's
doing this year
that's the squad looking
that's awesome though congratulations
babe
they just make fun of him for five
minutes no that's great dude that's good
hey man i didn't graduate it's all good
you look like you went swimming
i just caught a glimpse of you
[Applause]
[Music]
what i had some wings before i came out
here what the [ __ ]
[Applause]
i've never been so shocked on stage
i turn around and you're sucked
i'm not gonna stand here for this
[Applause]
i'm sorry that was the [ __ ] my mind was
like why what though [ __ ]
can i get a mozzarella stick or
something up here at least
i can die something dab it off
you got an english muffin i can soak
this up
there's still good butter in there
like after you've done the pasta with
the bread you're [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i have a heart attack then you'll be
sorry oh my god
but that clip will be cooking baby
oh my head hurts dude that threw me
through a loop all right
all right let's get back on track
uh ryan ryan m's question are you
garbage if you only serve two beverage
options at your wedding bud light and
milk
both
both in pictures at the end of the
buffet line
what are you [ __ ] half amish what the
[ __ ]
your sister's wedding
options
uh yes that is [ __ ] major trash
let me ask you this how much you give at
the wedding what kind of key issue was
in the envelope
then you drink your milk and shut up
yeah
you take whatever you get [ __ ]
[Applause]
oh there you go
she's classy clap it up for her
also i would love if she's lying that's
even better
she's like you idiots 200.
that's great clap it up for them that's
[ __ ] beautiful thank you that was
awesome
this one i don't even get ever bought a
horse at a garage sale
[Applause]
would you sell them the horse what the
[ __ ] he's like gary got you good you
[ __ ]
and i overcharged you too
could have got two horses for that
all right [ __ ] horse who is it troy
what what i
what wait what kind of car does she
drive to the garage sale that she can
leave with horses
you leave them [ __ ] here i'll be back
in 20 minutes
with my son
i just pictured a hatchback like all
right everybody get in good boy oh boy
i assume they're living in the house
with you
you have a pastor okay what's a horse go
for a garage sale
and do you bargain you're like i'll give
you a nickel
throw in those three old playboys and we
got a deal
1500
your mom's rolling up the [ __ ] yard
sales [ __ ] thick like that
yeah who's she gary vee what the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
shows up with 10 grand at a [ __ ]
garage sale i can flip these horses for
2 grand
[Laughter]
it's easy arbitrage
give me those cabbage bags i sold them
on amazon for 15 grand made a killing
holy [ __ ]
that is [ __ ] beautiful give him a
round of
[Applause]
god
applause